les pieds dans l'eau à plaisir ce sera
bientôt de l'histoire ancienne après
avoir subi deux inondations en février
et juin 2016 dans le quartier de la
boissière
la ville était en train de recréer des
bassins de rétention d'eau au niveau des
terrains des peupliers six semaines de
travaux pour un coût de 160 19000 euros
il y avait des bassins nommé en valent
ils vont être déplacés a grandi et on va
aussi buzet de façon beaucoup plus large
l'écoulement des eaux
vous savez quand l'eau circule dans un
usage trop étroits après quand il sort
il ne peut pas se répandre et l'eau a
besoin de place un besoin d'un lit
d'installation quand elle déborde et à
partir de ce moment là il était question
il fallait absolument revoir tous les
côtés de l'écoulement il n'y avait pas
que les terrains des peupliers qui était
dans une problématique
il y avait également le quartier des
quelques maisons qui étaient en bas la
petite zone pavillonnaire une fois les
bassins terminé la ville remettra à flot
les terrains synthétiques submergé
pendant les inondations des équipements
utilisés principalement par les
scolaires et les associations sportives
de la commune
ça ça va demandera tout l'été pour
pouvoir effectivement les mettre en
route à partir du mois de septembre
si plus d'un million de largement quand
vous l'aménager complètement autour et
bien sûr nous on y avait ajouté en plus
des vestiaires donc ça coûte vraiment
cher mais c'est aujourd'hui ce que de
vendre les sportifs donc a pas de raison
qu'on ne fasse pas un accompagnement à
ce niveau là mais comme je le disais
nous sommes aidés par rapport aux
assurances en parallèle des travaux sur
les terrains la municipalité va en
profiter pour créer à quelques mètres un
parking supplémentaire de 72 places pour
fluidifier le stationnement sur le
secteur rendez vous début septembre pour
voir toutes ces transformations